[Music]
and curry speaks out about Matt Lauer's
sexual misconduct allegations in her
first TV interview since leaving The
Today Show in 2012 curry appeared on
Wednesdays CBS this morning and opened
up about her former co-workers firing in
November I can tell you that I I am NOT
surprised by the allegations what do you
mean by that and why you mean that
you're not surprised because we heard
things you knew things what does that
mean because you're asking me a very
direct question I can say that I would
be surprised if many women did not
understand that there was a climate of
verbal harassment that existed I think
it would be surprising if someone said
that they didn't see that 61 year old
news woman who is an advocate for the
me2 movement also weighed in on the
decision to promote Hoda Kotb
to share the news desk with Savannah
Guthrie the idea that women are involved
speaking to women is actually an overdue
idea so so absolutely I think it's a
good idea the fact that we are moving
against this imbalance of power is
absolutely overdue at the time it was
rumored that Curry's firing was due to
lack of chemistry with then co-anchor
Matt Lauer I'm sorry I couldn't get read
the ball over the finish line but man I
did try curry reflected on what she's
learned after her painful exit when we
open our arms wide to life all the good
and the bad if we can just open
ourselves wide to it and embrace it we
can learn we need to learn and we can go
on and and become better people and I
hope that I've done that
[Music]
you